today's topic somebody sent me this tick
tock video
my question is why are these beautiful
woman single bro
why don't my single bro why the [ __ ] am
i single guys cause you said bro five
times already next video
but you don't find that what about bro
bro
bro why don't you what look at this bro
no
no you know about that bro life
bro you said bro five times already you
know what i would expect if you turned
off the lights okay and if i couldn't
see you
and i was just hearing this i'd be like
why the [ __ ] am i single bro
bro
why the [ __ ] am i single bro bro
bro why the [ __ ] am i single bro
bro
why the [ __ ] am i single bro bro
bro that's what i would expect kind of
energy but you know what
everyone's built different
it's just when you talk you say bro and
you taste yourself too much
yeah
like
bro
like but maybe it's just a cultural
thing maybe latinos say bro uh
i don't think it i don't even know if
it's a team it sounds very italian or
no this is tex-mex this is tex-mex yeah
never mind and carry on yeah american
too i've been single
i'm gonna be single oh my god i'm gonna
be single
for four [ __ ] years now in a few
months [ __ ] i haven't had a boyfriend
like officially no dude and i just think
about it and i look at myself and i'm
like [ __ ]
you're [ __ ] pretty [ __ ] like i'm not
trying to sound like you know i'm an
egoistic or whatever but like dude i'm
pretty a [ __ ]
i gotta ass
[ __ ] i got my own place i make my own
money i cook i clean
maybe you're bad [ __ ] crazy
maybe
there's some guys that i know that are
single
they're bad [ __ ] crazy
that's why
americans they like they lack
self-awareness
you can't have all the package the abs
and everything
you crazy you crazy
and i'm gonna tell you this it's gonna
be even worse for ladies
there are more ladies than men
more
some of y'all gonna be single
on both sides but if we look at the
numbers not everybody's gonna find that
somebody
not everybody
i got i have a friend
she told me she said that shout out uh
claudia she said
i think i'm not my types type
think about it i understood i think i'm
not my types type there's that the guys
i want i'm probably not their type so
there's that
there's maybe you're bad [ __ ]
maybe you're annoying
maybe a lot of things maybe a lot of
things or maybe
your boyfriend doesn't want you to
you can't call him a boyfriend because
it's not the guy that you're you know
maybe the guy that you're with you know
your boyfriend doesn't want you to call
him bro
tell your story back when i was 19 i was
dating this girl and we were dating
we've seen each other for like three
four months and uh
i was like yeah yeah you might homie and
she's excuse me
i was like yo what up homie what's wrong
yeah i called my friends homie though
yeah but i was dating her oh yeah
yeah she's like excuse me i was like
what's wrong i'm saying what don't call
me homie i was like that's a tear of
endearment nah it's like i call my mom
homie too say i'm not your mom i was
like [ __ ] this is not getting any better
he was right
[Laughter]
you did all that [ __ ] in front of the
camera and they'll be like yeah yeah you
were playing you're super big i was
being positioned yeah yeah yeah but uh
i do senora shin i'm not even a [ __ ]
senora
like
i got long hair pedo like i got long
hair i got a booty i look cute i look
good okay pero like i don't even
understand why these guys they don't
want to date me like bro i don't
understand bro
i kind of do
i got a good personality i'm funny
so sometimes i got an attitude but i'm
not like crazy
sometimes i got an attitude but i'm not
crazy means that you're crazy and you
got an attitude that's what it means
that's what it means nobody's gonna be
like yeah i'm you know what yeah i'm
i'm crazy that's why i need to tone
sometimes i get a little physical but
i'm not abusive you know what i'm saying
like sometimes i put my hands on him but
it's not like violent violent bro
is it that hard like is it a hard
finding of like a good genuine person
[ __ ] bro am i gonna be single forever
no
guys guys
i'm kind of freaking out
like is it that [ __ ] hard [ __ ]
anyways i'm gonna go cry that's great
that's good video
it's great content maybe she's not even
single she's doing that you know likes
and [ __ ] but
i don't know i don't know you okay dog
that [ __ ] that we said was really just
for comedy right i was not
i was not
believing none of that i don't know you
i don't know you hey what yeah
but if you're single
you're the common denominator of all
that single thing you know i mean
there's a lot of things that could
happen and there's a lot of reason why
you could be single a lot of things this
is the female version of the supreme
gentleman okay remember that dude who
went up to that school and shot up
everyone but he did that video just
before where he's like
i have my own car look at these shades
these are three thousand dollar shades
i'm a gentleman the way i treat women
i'm such a kind man
and these women they just
they act like i'm invisible
well you're gonna see me today [ __ ] and
then he went up and shot up the whole
school
really yeah he called himself the
supreme gentleman that's his tape isn't
this a female i don't understand well
i'm not desire it's just the other end
of that spectrum
this is the other end of that
spectrum here's the truth you know
oftentimes these ladies are attractive
and who have these struggles most of the
time it's just they don't find guys that
they find attractive enough to be with
them there's plenty of dudes who line up
but they just don't need to look
standard or they're not tall enough or
they're not this enough and you know
sometimes when people say they can't
find me what they're really saying is
considering my really high standards i
can't find someone who meets them and
you know
do i feel bad for people
no
all the people that you want that one
person that you want there's a lot of
y'all [ __ ] fighting for that
and you got to be
something very specific and special to
get that
or not you just got just got to know
like i said everyone learns to settle
for things in life and if you don't want
to that's fine keep rolling them dies
watch the tears go by and after that
if you don't and you still find someone
well you played the game and you're lost
and it's okay
but not everyone deserves somebody who
meets their standards especially if your
standards aren't reasonable
that's pretty much all i have
anything else you would like to say to
the young lady
bro
i'm not gonna go in front of you like if
some girl comes on some like hella
masculine energy talking about yo what
up bro
yeah no that's pretty nasty it's like
you know what the thing is like if
someone sent me a meme like that but
it's it's kind of true it was kind of
funny he's like yo i want i'm sorry i
just can we have feminine women back
could you i won't have i want to i'm
sick and tired of those genuine soldiers
and i was like
there's some girls sometimes they come
up to you like yo man what up dude you
look my cute i'm like what all in the
dress and everything and stuff i'm like
well that's not but here's the thing i
don't want to hear yeah dude [ __ ] me
hard like what if you if you rolled up
on a girl you're like man look at this
feminine [ __ ] yo come over here ma like
you would she would definitely be like
huh
she would have been like huh yeah
exactly
you feminine ass [ __ ] come here
looking all buffy [ __ ] listen i know
you're talking about a girl but it
sounds gay exactly that sounds gay but
exactly so when the girl come in with
that yo what up you look my it's weird
it's the display is weird the bro this
the hands yeah don't don't don't don't
come with that frat energy okay unless
you're lebanese or italian which is
pretty much the same thing you shouldn't
be yelling bro every five seconds
okay
or greek fair but greek they don't say
bro no it's these in a time yeah
yeah
but if a girl comes to me it's like yo
ray
yo my bro come here you look good though
no it's going to be weird yeah it's
going to be weird looking these people
are pretty much at times with a bit of
like
like tzatziki sauce greeks are are are
italians with spinach
yes yes
little fed on top
a little bit of olive oil
the bro is one level that is another
level so my advice to you ladies don't
be out here talking to every dude like
bro
i'm not saying it's gonna stop you but
it's pretty nasty it's just it's just
it's not that appealing and ladies you
guys don't want to be talked to like
most ladies don't want to be talked to
like that either
no all this to say don't follow my
example all right young lady i advise
you maybe not to you say bro as much or
even curse as much it's uh
yeah but do you you know i mean live
your best life it's working out anyways
let us know what you guys think in the
comments below
[Music]
me
[Applause]
[Music]
bye